So chemically speaking, DNA and RNA are incredibly
similar. They're not exactly the same. While DNA
is made of deoxynucleotides because it's ribosugar is
missing an oxygen. And here, the ribosugar is
this black pentagon here. RNA's made of nucleotides.
Which I'm showing in this, sort of, light
blue pentagon, meaning that it has an extra
oxygen. So this is how I'm going to distinguish them,
from here on out whenever we have this
kind of structure here. Now, nucleotides have nitrogenous
bases, just like deoxynucleotides do. You can see
the colorful structures in the DNA and in
the RNA. And long sequences of these nucleotides
can be strung together, one right after another,
in DNA as well as RNA. But there's
one big difference. In the four letter alphabet
of nitrogenous bases between DNA and RNA. Just making a
few comparisons here, I want you to see if you
can answer three questions for me. I want you to
look at the strands and tell me what DNA letter
is missing in RNA and I want you to tell
me what new RNA letter appears. And I want you
to tell me what letter that new RNA letter might
base pair with. Go ahead and see if you can
answer those three questions in the text boxes here.